I forgot to finish our
examples for group by, so
let's go ahead and jump
into those examples. My bad.
All right, so looking at the
examples for the group by,
we are going to, again, I've provided
this file for you to download.
Go ahead and download and follow along
with me. I have just copied these
in here and put dashes in front of
each of the questions so that we
can type the queries beneath them.
So I'm going to find the average age
of guests who have a season pass
and for guests who do not have a
season pass. Okay, I want to know the
average age of guests. So I'm just
going to, again, start out with a
handy select star from guest, okay?
So I go ahead and run this, and now
I have all of my guests returning
to me and all of the fields as well.
So the average age of guests who
have a season pass and for guests
who do not. So let's just start off
with what we know. So we know that
we're going to perform average on
the age field, and I need to give this
an alias. so average age as average
age, okay? So now when I run this,
I know that my average age is
26. But I want to know for guests
who have a season pass and for guests
who do not. So I want to see the
average age for those who have a season
pass, the average age for those
that do not. So I know that I want
to see that, right? So therefore
what I want to see, I want to put in
my select clause clause because I
want to see the season pass status.
Now, think to yourself, will this run?
No, it will not run because
I have an aggregate function,
right, average being performed on
the age field and a non-aggregated
field of season pass in my
select clause. Therefore, I
must group by the season pass
status. Okay. So now when I go
ahead and run this, again, And
I'm just doing Control-Enter.
I can see here that I have the
average age for those that do not have
a season pass is 27. And the
average age for those that do is 32.
But then I can see here that I have
a season pass status that just kind
of looks, it doesn't say null, but
it may just have a space in there.
It's a data quality issue. And that
average age, more than likely of
that one individual. there may be a
few individuals with just the space
is 60. So that is a data quality
issue that we found, right? Really
interesting. But if I wanted to get
rid of that basically space here just
for the purposes of this query, I
could add an aware clause here and say
where season pass in, and I I could
say just list Y and comma N, right?
It's qualitative data. It's going
to be contained within SQL quotes.
Now when I run this, now I'm
only receiving my yes or my no in
terms of they do or do not have
a season pass. But we found a
data quality issue, something
we should look into and address.
I'm down to question two. For each
season in the database, how many
new employees joined the company?
Okay, let's take a look at this. So if
I come over here to my guest table,
I can see here I have a guest,
first name, last name, gender, age.
Oh, but I'm talking about employees.
That's right. So let's look at
employees. So employee, I can see here
I have a season filled. So let's
scroll down and look at the employee
season filled. So the season filled
is a small int. It's the first
year of season in which employed,
meaning it's like I started here in
2016. I started here in 2020, whatever
that may be. I started here in
2025, 2026, whatever. Okay. So let's
go ahead and take a look at this.
So for each season in the
database, so let's go ahead and
write this query. So I'm going
to select, and I want to,
I'm just going to do select
star from employee here quick.
And I can see here that I have
these seasons, right, and the
employee's information. So now
when I take a look at this,
how many employees join the
company? So I'm going to say select
count, and I want to count the
rec ID, which is going to be
the primary key for the employee
table as num of employees,
okay?
And then I'm going to
select season, okay?
Now, will this run? I hope you said
no. It will not run because I'm
aggregating rec ID, and then I have
a non-aggregated field of season.
So now I'm going to say group by
season, okay, my non-aggregated
field. And now I can see here that
I have this many employees that
joined the company during these
seasons. So 219 joined in 2016,
212 joined in 2022, and so on
and so on. So now I can see the
total number of employees who
joined per season, which could be
insightful data. Which season have
we recruited the most employees?
And think through that that
way. Now for each season in the
database, how many new employees
were assigned operation roles.
Okay, so now we only want to count
employees who have an operation
role. Now, when we're thinking
about this, we want to look at
new employees, right? So we're
answering the same question here,
but we want to limit it to
only employees who were in the
operation role. So let's take a
look. Let's do a quick select star
from employee and what we see here
is in this operation role or in
these roles let me zoom out so you
can see it's a little bit better um we
can see here they're assigned okay
so they were maybe requested to be
in operations but they were assigned
to sales retail so we want to
say we're assigned equal to operations
right and we could double check
that in our data dictionary if we
look here at a requested, this is the
employee's requested position, and
then assigned is the position to
which employee was assigned. So now
what I want to do is I only want
to count the records of which they're
assigned is equal to operations.
So if I was to write this down
here, I'd say, you know, where
assigned equals to operations. Now
I'm only going to return employees
at this point where they're
assigned is equal to operations,
okay? So if we take a look
at this, I scroll over here,
assigned is all operations. So that's
what I want to do up here in my
select clause where I'm doing my
little bit more advanced querying
technique up here. And I'm saying that
I only want to see new employees who
are assigned to operations roles.
So what I need to do is I'm going
to copy this where clause and paste
it or just write it again up here.
And again, where comes after from
and before group by and the order,
right? That's very important. And
so now it's only going to account
employees where assigned is equal to
operations, right? Remember the where
clause limits what records are
returned to me. And in this case, it's
limiting what records are counted.
Therefore, I'm only counting the
number of operations employees, okay?
So now when I run this, I can see
here that I have 52 operations
employees that were hired in 2016, 51 in
2017, and on down. So my where
clause is absolutely still applicable
when I'm dealing with group by,
right? It's very, very important that
that is limiting the records that we
are, in this case, counting. Okay.
All right. Thanks everybody. There's our
examples for today. Let's keep moving on.